e con quali i capelli ve lo sto dicendo
ragazzi sono tutti ragazzi intervenuti a
questo video sono dj ed oggi siamo in un
log e non so quanti minchiate andrà
inseriti in questo blog perché credetemi
stavolta forse ci superiamo ed è grave
prima di cominciare di ripartire con la
forma bella settimana che questa
settimana è stata vinta da lucrezia che
ha fatto questo disegno che io d arte
non ci capisco un cazzo per lo so da
cosa sei un artista quindi il 100
dico io che sono esperto di arte sei un
artista passando le news ragazzi sarò
breve lo prometto nella prova non ridere
challenge avevamo raggiunto i 200 euro
per la donazione è ancora non sapevo a
chi donare alla fine ho deciso di donare
rami dell'associazione della fabbrica
del sorriso che lascio sempre linking
descrizione e quindi 200 euro per la
donazione della prova non ridere
challenge andranno a loro speriamo di
farne un'altra di prova non ridere
challenge diverte voi diverte me e aiuta
anche un sacco di persone quindi sono
contento di farlo presto ne arriva un
altro questo lunedì uscirà un video su
un videogame che da cinque anni volevo
fare questo campo e 5
ve lo giuro e niente vedrete che roba è
lo con un motivo lo conosceranno già
però io ne ho viste ad una mazza se
doveste dire che possiamo passare al
pezzo forte del blog di oggi che
recentemente ho fatto un evento a
rainbow magicland un parco divertimenti
ho fatto anche le montagne russe che mi
piacciono un sacco
no ragazzi dovete capire una roba le
montagne russe e soprattutto quella
cagata che sale in alto e poi sganciati
fa scendere di botto mi fanno cagare
dagli occhi queste dove sei domani a
domani siano su quel coso lì perché
voglio sentire le urla senti le urla non
scendono
no
facciamo una scena in texas che riprendo
gli e tu passi ok vai tu
il ministro ma io io sto filmando tutto
come fare tutti e va a cadere
by kg perché lo fai solo per i tuoi fans
[Musica]
adesso la dichiarazione
perfetto ragazzi abbiamo fatto una
giostra bella stiamo andando a fare
quella che casca di brutto giu e la
stessa faccia che avevi prima di
incontrare vale rossi mettere piedi ce
la faccia di vertigini mica go addosso
non sto scherzando toglimi sta merda
[Musica]
non si sente così voglio scendere mi fa
paura fra temi fortuna
oddio non va porco zio tavole spagna
morag aboliamolo quale o prendete non
può per il culo che non può fare niente
ma stessa è unire e niente ragazze
questo punto direi che possiamo passare
oltre visto che non è proprio il massimo
vale del giostra con famiglie e ragazzi
oggi non ce l'ho scartato dei pacchi
però c'è una roba affida alla ragazzi mi
è stato inviato un pacco gigantesco da
nerf nerf e o più presentano più dentro
una lettera fatemela leggere la lettera
contiene poche righe però che leggo
perché viva scassa agente speciale pavic
eni mette a star di benvenuto
all'interno della missione segreta
italian nair farei mai stata selezionata
dalla gente operativo e tuo avversario
francesco polla sa cosa ma che stai a
sfida per sfidarvi in una missione che
eleggerà il miglior nel ner vista tra
voi io lo osservo d'estate
e l'inverno nerf la tua datazione
consiste in un road cup che sarebbe
questo 2 strong arm e due ricariche di
dardi che ai ragazzini proietti proprio
i rok cup quindi questo cosa su doppia
canna spara due dardi per volta due alla
madonna
a oltre sei metri di distanza ecco
perché i due strong arm quindi questi
qua allenati perché la sfida avrà luogo
tra pochi giorni in una location segreta
e traversari ti diranno dardi è dato a
dargli da torce ragazzi l'ebreo vi
contatteremo altri presto in bocca al
lupo dal team italia nell arena non so
che cosa scegliere in realtà fatemi fare
un test
[Musica]
forse quello no facciamo proviamo questi
ok non so quanto possa riuscirci però ci
provo
non è vero non è vero non è possibile
[Musica]
non è possibile non è possibile non ci
credo mai ma come cazzo ho fatto ho
scelto ho scelto a posto
grazie ma non è possibile ma anni di b
gli addestramenti ma che cazzo ma cosa
ma è che ma cosa vuoi perché i ragazzi
accetto la sfida direi sommarsi vostri
voi prove per ultima cosa ragazzi se
inviate le fan art mostre a tema nerf
sulla pagina facebook di nef che vi
lascio sempre la descrizione i boss
della verso e sceglieranno i vincitori
per le fan art e chi farà la frana di
bella per partecipare come pubblico a
questa nostra sfida incredibile che si
terrà il 22 maggio
non vi dico dove perché questo effetto
psiche la data verrà posto di niente
ragazzi con quest o sono lasciate il mi
piace qui ma via a me voglio vedere
quindi ragazzi spero che i temi siamo
riuscito a io col crollo queerblog devo
scaricare l'adrenalina che ho accumulato
da polso tiro incredibile poi domanda
accordi probabilità ciò di riprovarci di
riuscirci in altra volta credo che
neanche il più grande matematico
specializzato in statistica possa avere
la risposta a questa domanda mi ragazzi
spero che il video vi sia piaciuto e
concludo che l'episodio come al solito
sei video è piaciuto lasciato un
commento era mi piace anche a pacini
facebook e come video statale iscrizione
se lo sapessi di schede ci vediamo un pò
subito i ragazzi